The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Right.
So you can see it's me again.
So George can have
a holiday again.
But he's not really
having a real holiday
because he's
actually sitting in.
And I guess one
reason why we decided
that he had to do that
was because I have
to use his computer
because he's written
these talks in this
strange application that
doesn't run on my computer.
So now we going to--
today, we're just about getting
into interesting stuff now.
Seems rather a long time since
the beginning of this course
before we get into the
real wave optics, which
I'm sure everyone would agree
is the most interesting part.
So this lecture is
about interferometry.
And then the next lecture--
I don't know how much I'm
going to get through today,
but the next lecture's
about diffraction.
So these are two
techniques, two phenomena
that are obviously very
closely related to each other.
So in this talk really two
types of interferometer--
the Michelson interferometer
and the Mach-Zehnder
interferometer.
So it took me a few minutes
to understand this picture.
But anyway, it
looks a bit messy.
But in the end, I--
George drew this,
obviously, otherwise
I wouldn't be saying that.
But what this is
showing, then, is
trying to show how a wave varies
both in distance and in time.
So the wave's propagating
along this z-direction.
So if you look
along this z-axis,
you will see this
amplitude variation
given by the black line.
So a cosine-type variation.
And then at any point, any
value of z, you can see,
plotted in red, how the
amplitude will change
with time along this axis here.
So you can see that you
get a sinusoidal variation
both in time and in space.
And a reminder here, then,
how you can express this wave.
This is a
sinusoidal-shaped wave,
which is moving in the
positive z-direction.
And you can either express
it in this form, which
is what you would actually
measure if you could really
measure it-- except that, as we
said before, you can't really
measure it because it's
moving too quickly.
But normally we do
the manipulations
on the expressions using this
complex notation because it
makes it easier to do the sums.
Yeah.
So this is showing, then--
this is a particular
value of distance,
then, and showing
how it changes here
the value of the phase of
this cosine wave at the time t
equals 0 according
to the value of z.
I guess what that's
trying to show.
And then let's think
now what happens
if we've got some plane
wave propagating along
at an angle with the axis.
So here's this
wave coming along,
which it's going along a line--
the direction of the
propagation of the wave
is along this
direction, which is
an angle theta with the axis.
And so you can see that when
this wave reaches this plane z
equals fixed here-- so this is
some plane where we might put
a screen or detector
or something--
you can see that the different
parts of this phase front
are going to strike this
plane at different times.
Or equivalent, you can say that
if you look at this plane here,
this wave will experience--
exhibit-- different
phase at different points
along this line.
And so this is what we're
looking at here then.
As it says here, the path delay
increases linearly with x.
So there'll be
somewhere where this
arrives at a phase of 0, which
I guess is this point here.
And then on one
side, the phase is
going to be positive
and negative, according
to which way you go.
So mathematically, this
is how we express this.
So this is our wave, the
same as the previous slide,
but now the wave is moving at
this angle theta to the axis.
So we get this term.
This is our-- you
remember, we expressed this
before as k.r for a wave moving
in general in a direction r.
And so this-- so we
could write this then.
This is what is in terms of
our phasor representation.
So as before, we write this
as an e to the i type thing.
And then we also--
this e to the minus i omega
t, we just missed that out
for clarity, just
because we don't
want to have to write
that every time.
So there's an e to
the minus i omega t
understood that we don't write.
And k, of course,
is 2 pi over lambda.
So k is related inversely to
the wavelength of the light.
And so this thing here,
this complex number here,
you could write this
as e to the i phi,
like this, where phi is the
phase of the wave, which
is a function of position.
And it can be written like this.
So if we look at a
particular value of z,
then this z is
going to be fixed.
So this part, e to the i 2
pi over lambda z cos theta,
is going to be fixed.
And the phase
variation is only going
to be because of
this other part here.
So this is another example.
And so this shows spherical
waves or rather distorted
spherical waves they become
because of the advances
in modern technology that
love to distort everything
you draw and make
it so that it's
not the right shape anymore.
But anyway, this is
a point source which
is giving out spherical waves.
And you can see that here
we put our screen again
or whatever it is
that z equals z0.
So you can see that these
waves, as they travel out here,
they're traveling a
different distance
before they get to the screen.
So you can see that's
going to do two things.
One is, of course, the amplitude
is going to decay as 1 over r.
So the amplitude of the wave
when it reaches out here
is going to be smaller
than the amplitude here.
But much more important
is the phase effect
because you can see
the phase actually
might change tremendously.
Because the
wavelength is so small
compared with
these distances, it
means that you only have to
go quite a small distance
before you get a big
change in the phase.
So that's what we want
to be able to quantify.
And so here we're riding
our spherical wave,
just like we did before.
So George has kept this the
same as he's said before.
You'll notice that it's
got this funny pi over 2
in there, which he
introduced that before.
It has the effect of making
this like a sine, of course.
Something minus pi
by 2 is like sine.
This is actually like
a sinc type function.
And that's the reason why
that pi over 2 is there.
It's so that it
doesn't blow up when
you look at what
happens at x equals
y equals z equals t equals 0.
If you didn't have
the pi over 2 there,
you'd have horrible infinities.
So you avoid those by
putting this pi over 2 there.
And yeah.
So this is the radius.
r is just the square
root of x squared
plus y squared plus z squared.
So this is kr minus omega t.
And this is our r at the bottom.
And now we make
an approximation.
The approximation
we're going to make
is that we're not actually
really looking at this geometry
as shown in the picture, but
we're looking at the geometry
when, actually, we're only
looking in a small region
near to the axis.
What that really, in
physical practice,
that means is that this
distance z0 becomes very large.
We're a long way
away from the source.
And so we can think of this
value z being a very large.
Sorry.
You understand my
funny English language,
don't you, when I
talk about "zeds"?
What you call "zees."
I just suddenly realized that.
Anyway.
So we've already had this before
in earlier lectures as well.
This is a square root that
we can expand by the binomial
and assume that z is large
much larger than x and y.
So you take out a factor
z, and the square root
becomes 1 plus a half-something.
And so eventually you
get this sort of thing.
So that's what we do
inside this phase term.
But the thing at
the bottom, we say
we don't have to be
so careful with that
because it's not so
sensitive to this amplitude
because all it does
is just changes
the magnitude of the
wave by a small amount.
Because we've said
x and y is small.
But up here, you have to be
more careful because we're
talking about phases.
So anyway, at the bottom, we
can just neglect the x and y.
So that's where the z
has come from there.
And when we do this
binomial thing on the top,
we get this
expression here then.
So the dependence on
x and y, you can see,
just becomes a
quadratic type term--
x squared plus y
squared over 2z.
And so this is what this
picture is drawing here.
The path delay increases
quadratically with x.
So as you go further,
this point here
corresponds to the
center of the screen.
And then as you go
further away, this
increases with some parabolic
variation like this.
So that's doing it in
terms of the cosines.
If we go in terms of the
complex exponentials,
much the same sort of approach.
You can just expand,
again, the square root
inside the exponential now.
Exactly the same, really.
And you end up getting
this expression here.
And so this is an
example now, you
can see, of the power of
this complex exponential form
though because this complex
exponential of here two, terms
or it might be more
terms in general,
you can just expand
them, can't you?
You can just say that
multiplied together.
Whereas if it was
cosine, of course,
you'd have to remember all
these things-- cos of a plus
b plus c.
Horrible.
I don't know why I'm
making funny noises.
Maybe I shouldn't keep
getting too near the speakers.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
So with the complex
exponentials,
we can break it up very simply.
And this inside the braces,
then, is our phi before,
or i phi.
So we can say this is e0 e
to the i phi, where the phase
phi has just got this parabolic
term, plus some constant term,
which corresponds to
this, which corresponds,
of course to this distance--
the phase that you get through
traveling in that distance
there.
So that's how you
get a phase delay.
AUDIENCE: I've got a question.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What happened to
the pi over 2 in the phasor?
COLIN SHEPPARD: What happened
to the pi over 2 in the phasor?
So we've got good--
it's there, isn't it?
And then it's disappeared.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
COLIN SHEPPARD:
Ah, the i outside.
There it is.
It's that one.
Yeah.
OK.
So it's an i outside.
And yeah.
That's an interesting-- I
think George said something
about that before
because effectively it
makes this wave 90
degrees out of phase.
And I like to think
of that as being
related to some sort of
resonance-type phenomenon.
If you excite something
that resonates,
then it's going to resonate 90
degrees out of phase, isn't it?
So if you've got a point source
and you excite it with a wave,
then the scattered wave is going
to be 90 degrees out of phase
with the driving force, just
because it's like a resonance.
And I guess that's also
true in the Huygens' thing
that we come on in
the next lecture.
But yeah.
OK.
Thanks for pointing that out.
I'd forgotten that.
OK.
Other than that
it's fine, isn't it?
I hope.
So we're now going on
to discuss something
about the significance there.
Yeah.
So the point is, I
mentioned that there
is this modulus term,
intensity-type term.
But this is a very weak change.
So you can imagine, if you're
trying to do an experiment,
to actually measure the
properties of that wave field
by looking at the intensity
would be quite tough because we
said that these two
terms are very much
smaller than that one.
So looking at the
phase of the signal
is a much more sensitive way
to look at that wave front.
And as it says, the
phase can tell us
all sorts of things
about the wave,
like where the wave has come
from, how far it's traveled,
the materials it's gone
through, and generally
the optical path,
which you remember
we had optical path
before, integral ndz.
So that will change the phase.
And so if we can
measure the phase,
we can find out information
about those things.
The problem, though,
as we've said before,
is that the phase is not
something you can actually see
directly, because it's so fast.
So 10 to the minus--
10 to the 15 hertz is typical.
Very, very fast.
Much faster than you can
measure with any electronics.
So how do we do this?
We do it by some form
of interferometry,
which is basically mixing
it with a reference beam.
And then you look at the
intensity of the interference
between the two waves.
So this is how we do it.
So I said that
we're going to look
at two types of interferometer.
The first one is the
Michelson interferometer.
So this is how you make a
You get light from some
source and split it
into two parts with
a beam splitter.
And one of those beams is
what we call the signal arm.
This is what we're going
to try and measure.
So here, this shows this light
going through some object,
and then being
reflected by a mirror,
and then coming
back to a detector.
And then the other arm
is the reference arm.
So this is going to
produce a reference signal.
So effectively, we're
going to be comparing
the phases in those two arms.
So the reference
beam comes down also.
So these add together.
So we can add them as phasors.
This is for the reference beam.
Ar e to the i phi r.
For the signal beam we've
got As e to the i phi s.
We add the amplitude because
we're assuming it's coherent.
Maybe I ought to stress
that a bit, of course.
So this is assuming that
this is a coherent--
these two beams a coherent
with respect to each other.
So if you had light here from
a laser, that would be true.
And we'll probably
come onto cases where
it might not be true later on.
Once we've got the
amplitude, then we just
have to find the modulus
square to find the intensity.
And if you remember,
there's actually
a proportional sign here.
There's some funny
constants with epsilon
a half and things, which we
just don't usually worry about.
So these phases tell
us the optical path
that the light has gone
through in these two arms
in order to get to the detector.
And so what we're
measuring is the difference
in the optical path
in those two arms.
And so this shows
how that can work.
So this is an example where
these two waves arrive in phase
with each other.
So then they'll
add constructively
and you'll get a big
signal like that.
On the other hand, you could
imagine that they might not
arrive like that.
They might arrive in anti-phase
like this, in which case
you can see the two waves
now are going to cancel out.
And you're not going to
see now any interference.
In practice, of course, it could
be anything in between here.
All right.
So as you change--
you can change the relative
phase of this light
by changing the position
of this mirror or the size
or refractive index
of this object
that's in there, or the
wavelength of the light,
or whatever.
It's going to depend
on all of these things.
So example, measuring distance.
So we've said that
effectively what we're doing
is measuring the optical path.
So optical path depends on
a few things, doesn't it?
Optical path depends
on the distance,
it depends on the
wavelength, and it depends
on the refractive index.
So these are all things
that you can measure
using this sort of system.
So here it's talking
as an example.
There's no object
in this one anymore.
So this is just free space.
And so in this case,
then, what you can measure
is the difference in the optical
path in this arm and this arm.
And the optical path--
well, the refractive index
is now the same in each,
the wavelength's
the same in each,
so you could measure
the distance.
So this is an interferometer
for measuring distance.
So where could you use this?
Well, imagine, this might not
actually be a flat mirror.
It might actually have some
structure there, in which case
you could actually measure
what that structure is,
or if it was a mirror,
you could actually
use this to accurately measure
the distance of this mirror.
How far away it is from the
instrument, so to speak.
So the interesting thing--
another interesting thing--
this is the Michelson
interferometer.
And the Michelson
interferometer,
as the name says, was
invented by Michelson.
Well, I think he
probably invented it.
He certainly has his
name attached to it.
But he mainly used it
for measuring wavelength.
So we'll come back to that after
I've gone through the matter
bit, actually.
I think it's probably best.
Anyway.
So what we've said is we add
together these two phases,
find the modulus square, and
then we've got to expand that.
So this is a square of
a sum of two things.
So we're going to get the square
of this, the square of this,
and then we're going to
get some cross terms.
And this is what
it comes out to be.
The two cross terms, one
is the complex conjugate
of the other, which means that
when you add them together,
the final result is real.
That has to be true,
of course, because this
is an expression for intensity,
and intensity has to be real.
And so we've written
it in this nice form,
Ar squared plus As squared
plus 2 Ar As cos of something.
And this thing
here, the something,
is the difference between
the phases of the two beams.
So this next line
puts it into a sort
of general term, general form.
It's of the forms a
constant plus a cosine.
And then these quantities,
i0 m and delta phi,
you can also write in terms
of these other parameters
we had earlier.
So as it says, when
both paths are clear,
then these phases
adjust directly
proportional to the
distance ls and lr.
And so the phase difference
is just k times the difference
in the two paths.
So therefore, if you
measure the signal,
if you know what
the wavelength is,
you can measure what the
difference in those two
distances is.
There's a bit of
a proviso there,
which is quite a big proviso,
that you can only do this,
of course, modulo 2 pi.
So because this is a cosine,
it's going to keep repeating.
And you won't know which
of the cycles you're on.
So it means that interferometry
is usually very sensitive.
You can measure very, very small
distances, easily much smaller
than the wavelength.
And people sometimes talk
about measuring hundredth
of an Angstrom and
amazing small quantities
using interferometry.
The LIGO project, I don't
know what they're claiming.
10 to the minus 15 meters
or something they're
trying to measure to detect
these gravitational waves.
Anyway.
Yeah.
So you only measure
it modulo 2 pi.
So that means that if you're
trying to use this method
to measure-- for
example, I'm looking
at the door at the back
of the lecture theater.
If I'm trying to
use this to measure
the distance of that door,
I can measure the distance
to an accuracy,
maybe, of something
smaller than a micron.
But I wouldn't really know
whether it had added to that 10
meters or whatever.
So that actually has been what--
a lot of people have
put effort into trying
to develop interferometric
methods that you
can get that extra information
so that you can actually
do what we call unwrapping,
because this is like--
they sometimes call
this phase wrapping.
The phase wraps
because of the cosine.
And so you don't know which
of these lobes you're on.
Yeah.
Well, going back to Michelson.
So Michelson did this
the other way around.
He knows this distance
and uses this expression
to find the wavelength or
the k value or whatever.
And that's, of course, what
you do in an interferometer,
isn't it?
If you do a Fourier
transform interferometer,
you're using that as
a way of measuring
the wavelength of the light.
In the case of Michelson,
he looked at various things.
He didn't look at lasers because
there weren't any lasers then.
But he looked at light
from discharge tubes
and various different
types of lamp and so on.
And he looked at
how the signal would
vary as you move this mirror.
And it turns out that if
you do move the mirror
and you know accurately how
you're moving the mirror,
you can actually
work out from that
what the spectral
distribution of the source is.
That also suggests a way
around this wrapping problem.
The way around the wrap or a
way around the wrapping problem
is to use not just one
wavelength but many
wavelengths.
So even two wavelengths
is a big help, actually.
Yeah.
It's quite interesting
that Michelson--
I think I've spoken about
this with some of my students
before, that Michelson, he wrote
quite a lot about measuring
wavelengths using
that interferometer.
And then many, many
years later, people
came up with this
bright idea of using
what they call the low
coherence interferometer
or the white light
interferometer
to measure distances.
But as far as I know,
Michelson never suggested this.
I've never found it in
any of these papers.
Anyway.
So this is another application.
Here we're going to
look at a real object
that we put in there and try
and find out something about it.
So we put in this lump
of material, length
l, a certain refractive index.
And you can see now then that
the phase of this light when
it gets there is going to be
changed by the light traveling
through that material.
And have we taken
into account, George,
that it's gone
through twice here,
or even on the previous one?
There ought to be a 2 in there.
There ought to be a 2
in here, oughtn't there?
All right.
So the phase difference
is actually twice this
because it has this amount of
phase difference on the way
in and on the way out.
So I hadn't noticed
that before either.
But it applies to
this next one as well.
So this one, the light goes
through this object here.
And so there's this
extra phase delay
that comes because of this
object, which is this bit here.
So again, there ought
to be a factor of 2
for all of these terms.
And so there we are, though.
We've got this
extra optical path
and so now we can measure the
optical path of that object.
Again, modulo 2 pi.
So if this is many
wavelengths, you
might have trouble
to know exactly how
long it is, of course, because
of the wrapping of the phase
again.
So this modulo 2 pi we
can actually measure--
this is the optical
path difference.
n minus 1 times L.
The minus, of course,
is because the other--
the reference beam
has gone through air
when this has gone
through this material.
So what we measure is n minus 1
times L. If you knew what n is,
we can know what L is.
If we knew what L is,
we could know what n is.
But as it says there, if
you don't know either,
then you can't find either.
All you know is
what n minus 1 L is.
Anyone got any ideas
about how you might--
what might you do
to get both of those
if you wanted to
know both of those?
Any ideas how you could do that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Based
on what, though?
You'd have to have
two measurements.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Press the button, please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Yeah.
Someone says it's to use
two wavelengths to set up
simultaneous equations.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Exactly.
Good one.
Yeah.
Who said it?
Someone in the back said it.
AUDIENCE: I heard it somewhere.
COLIN SHEPPARD:
You're not getting
the full credit for that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
COLIN SHEPPARD:
Anyway, someone got it.
So yeah.
So if you measured this for
two different wavelengths,
then you could have a pair
of simultaneous equations,
and you could solve
for both of those.
That, of course, assuming
that there is no dispersion.
If n changes with
wavelength, then you
are still back to square
one, unless you do
some more wavelengths I guess.
But anyway, yeah.
So it just shows
you, though, you
can do a lot of these
experiments very easily.
So now let's sort
of-- these are used--
this Michelson
interferometer is used
a lot in metrology,
industrial sort of metrology.
And all countries have their--
in the US, it used to
be called the National
Bureau of Standards, didn't it?
But I don't know that
that exists anymore.
AUDIENCE: It's called NIST.
COLIN SHEPPARD: NIST.
NIST.
That's right.
It changed.
I don't know why it
changed its name.
But anyway, so all
countries have got this.
They have this
standard measures.
They have procedures for
calibrating distances
and so on.
And the idea is that if a
company like General Motors
is making parts for a
car, that those parts will
fit as a spare for another car
that's made by another factory.
So say you make
some shaft that's
supposed to be 1
inch in diameter,
you want it to be
accurately 1 inch diameter.
Otherwise, the
bit from one place
wouldn't fit the
bit from the other.
There is actually a
true story about that.
A thing called the Vickers inch.
Vickers is an engineering
company in the UK.
And this Vickers
inch was a big thing
that came up during
the Second World War,
where lots of
factories all over UK
were converted to
make munitions.
And somewhere down
the line, people
realized that Vickers had a
different inch from everyone
else.
So when they made
a shell and tried
putting it in the barrel of
the gun, it didn't quite fit.
So eventually that
was sorted out.
They worked out what
the problem was.
And I guess it's that sort
of problem that makes it
so that the companies now--
obviously the countries keep
these standards and so on.
So the sort of
thing you might do
is measure the height of this.
Let's say you put in--
they have these things
called gauge blocks.
A lot of you are
mechanical engineers
so you must know
about gauge blocks.
So you can buy these
standard lumps of metal that
have got a certain thickness.
And so you put this
lump of metal in here
and measure the thickness of
it using an interferometer.
So these standards,
of course, they
have these what they
call primary standards,
and then they're handed down.
I'm not quite sure how
the length works anymore,
but it's all defined in terms
of the wavelength of something,
isn't it?
And then all of the
countries around the world,
they all have to
compare their meter
to make sure that they've
all got the same meter.
And then within each country--
so in the US, NIST would then
be measuring these gauge blocks
that would be sent to
them from other companies
to make sure that they've
got the right size.
And then in the
companies, then they
would compare those gauge
blocks against other gauge
blocks and other things.
So this is what you use-- one
of the things you use this for.
So now, fringe visibility.
Yeah.
So we've said that
you get these fringes.
Perhaps I ought to go back
and explain that a bit more.
Back to this one.
So you can see here
we've got a constant term
plus a sinusoidal-type term
or cosinusoidal-type term.
And you can see that this
term m is called the contrast
or fringe visibility.
So if m is 1, then you can see
that they are going to be--
for particular
values of delta phi,
this intensity is
going to go to 0.
So that's when you get--
you've got very high
fringe visibility.
And you can see
that this visibility
depends on this, Ar 2 Ar As
over ir squared plus As squared.
And you can show
quite easily that that
is going to reach a maximum.
It's going to be equal
to 1 when Ar equals As.
So if you ensure
that Ar equals As,
then you're going to get
your visibility of 1.
I guess it can't be bigger
than 1 because that would
mean that the intensity
would go negative,
which is not possible.
So this plots what it is--
what you would see as
a function of delta phi
and for a particular value of n.
So there's some background,
sometimes called the bias.
And then you've got some
wiggles on top of that.
And so this plot is
plotted against delta phi.
Delta phi could change by
a number of different ways,
of course.
One way it could change is if
you actually move the mirror.
Another way it could change
is if you tilted the mirror.
If you tilted the
mirror, then there'd
be different delta phis
at different transverse
positions on the mirror.
And if we take Ar equal As, then
you've got perfect contrast,
m equals 1.
You see it goes
right down to zero.
And that's the high
visibility of the fringes
that you can get.
If, on the other hand,
you find that if you take,
let's say, the
reference beam to be
much stronger than
the signal beam,
then you can see that m
is going to tend to zero.
The contrast is going
to become very weak.
Actually, sometimes
people do do that.
Contrast is not necessarily
the most important thing
because if you notice what
we had before, you see that--
let's go back to
the previous one.
Yeah.
Let's go back to this one here.
You can see that you've
got these three terms.
So what we're saying
is if you make
Ar much bigger than As, then
you make the contrast is going
to get smaller and
smaller because obviously
this term is going to become
much bigger than this one.
But nevertheless, it does
actually make this term bigger.
So if actually what
you're trying to do
is measure this signal in
some background of noise,
it's sometimes a good thing
to make Ar bigger than As
because as you increase Ar,
it increases the strength
of this interference term.
And that's the
principle that's used
in heterodyne interferometry.
So not always true that you try
and make the contrast as big
as possible.
Yeah.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: There
is one more factor of 2
missing here.
On the left-hand side bottom,
the swing of the fringes
should be 2m times
i0 times-- yeah.
There's a factor of 2 missing.
That's quite unusual.
Three slides in a row.
They're all missing
a factor of 2.
COLIN SHEPPARD: And
they don't cancel out.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
I guess.
COLIN SHEPPARD: OK.
So that's the Michelson
interferometer.
So the Michelson interferometer
is basically, you can see,
a sort of reflection
interferometer.
And we're now going to
go into the Mach-Zehnder
interferometer, which is
basically a transmission
interferometer.
So the principle
is very similar.
You split the light
into two parts.
The two paths-- two light beams
go through different path,
and then you combine
them onto a detector.
So this works in
transmission mode.
Here you're looking
through an object.
So now you're not going
to get that factor of 2,
of course, because the light
is only going through it once.
So the light goes through here.
You notice that the way
this has been drawn,
it's been drawn so that this
light is going like this,
this light is going like this.
So you can see this path and
this path are roughly equal.
You might equally-- well, you
could have thought of making
this by doing it more like--
couldn't you?
You could have
done it like that.
So where now you can see, if
we'd have made it like that,
this path is obviously
longer than that path.
So I guess nowadays if
you did that experiment
with a laser which has
got a very long coherence
length, something like a
frequency double YAG laser,
this would work fine.
If you tried doing this with
an arc lamp or something
like that it wouldn't work
because this distance is
much longer than the coherence
length of the source.
So you're all used to the
idea that actually you
don't see interference
fringes all the time.
In the normal,
regular, everyday life
you don't see interference
fringes very much.
And that's because
in everyday life,
normally the light is
incoherent rather than coherent.
So if you make this system here
or the Michelson interferometer
we showed before and you make
it so that these paths are
accurately the same
length, then you
could get interference
even with light from a--
you can get interference even
from light from a tungsten lamp
bulb.
And they produce really
nice, beautiful fringes
with different colors.
Maybe my students maybe
have seen these in the lab.
But anyway.
So here you can use this
to measure the optical path
of some object.
And yeah.
So this is now, again,
looking at this idea
of tilting something.
I mentioned about tilting
with regard to the Michelson
interferometer.
I said, if you tilt
one of those mirrors,
you would actually get the
optical path varying linearly
with transverse distance.
So if you actually
looked at an image
of that interference,
what you would see
would be a series of fringes.
And the spacing
between the fringes
would increase as you
increase the angle.
So this is the same here.
We're getting the offset
between these two paths--
these two beams-- by rotating
this mirror slightly.
And then as you can see,
these two beams arrive
on a CCD camera, it shows here.
So you will actually--
in this case,
you would get some
variation in intensity
on this detector, which
you could actually
measure with the detector.
So it would look
something like this.
This would now be,
then, a function of x
rather than just being a
function of the optical path
difference.
So this bit here, I guess, is
explaining, is deriving that.
So we're adding
two wave together.
One is arriving normally.
The other one is tilted
through an angle theta.
And so this one here is going
to have a linear phase variation
as a function of x, which will
then appear inside this cosine.
So finally what
we get here then,
the value of this bit
here, the z cos theta,
is just this constant here.
So all that does is it shifts
these fringes this way.
But normally, if you were
doing this experiment,
one thing you could
do then very simply
is to measure what this spatial
wavelength of these fringes is.
And from that you
could, for example,
if you knew all
the other things,
you could measure what
this rotation theta was,
couldn't you?
If you knew what the
rotation theta is,
then I don't know what
you could measure.
But you could measure
something, probably.
So the Mach-Zehnder,
I mentioned that this
is like a transmission
interferometer.
The Michelson is like a
reflection interferometer.
Both of these sorts
of interferometers
are used in
microscopy, actually.
And so you can make an
interference microscope
based on this technique.
And you could put
in here, let's say,
a biological slide with a bit
of tissue or something on it.
And you could use this to
measure the obstacle path
in going through that object.
It's not trivial to do that.
You'd normally, if you want
to do it in a microscope,
you'd have to place some
microscope objectives
and things in here.
And usually it's found
that if you do that, that
messes everything up.
So you normally have to put
the microscope objectives
in this one as well.
So you end up really having
to have two microscopes,
and the whole thing
becomes very expensive.
So that sort of method has
really gone out of fashion,
although many years
ago Zeiss and people
used to make
instruments like that.
The same goes for a Michelson
type interferometer.
You can measure
that for looking--
use that in a microscope
for looking at surfaces--
surface height
changes, and so on.
OK.
So this shows, again, how
this comes about, then.
You've got this one wave, which
is coming along this angle
here.
And so this
represents the phases.
This is a movie.
Do I just click it again and
it'll do something, will it?
Yes.
There we are.
OK.
So it didn't go very far.
Anyway.
Probably it was
quick enough to see.
It was a wave that's
moving this way.
But the important thing, if
I go back and do it again--
OK.
So you've all got
to watch this time.
And there's two things
I want you to watch.
One is the wave moving this way.
But more importantly, look
what happens on this line
here where you've got
the camera placed.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Right.
Yeah.
Otherwise, I think people
have to be very quick.
Yes.
Look at that.
OK.
So good.
So this wave is moving out here.
But you can see, if you look
at where the detector is,
it's as though the fringes--
the phase is actually
moving continuously
in one direction like that.
So right.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
So the point
is that the reference has
a constant phase because it
is normal on the vertical axis.
So as the incident wave
is passing through,
the peaks are the
locations where
the intensity accumulates.
So you end up getting a
peak, whereas in the nulls,
it means that as the
wave is passing through,
the phases are not lining up.
So you end up getting a null.
That's how you--
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah.
Yeah.
OK.
So I guess the reference
beam, as you say,
is coming along this way.
But of course, that's
got fringes as well.
So--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right.
COLIN SHEPPARD:
--the peaks of that,
when they match up with
the peaks of the other,
would give the maxima in the--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: There's
locations where the peaks
always arrive at the same time.
But a little bit
below, the peaks
will be actually out of phase.
So they end up getting a null.
COLIN SHEPPARD: End of show.
So that's the end of that.
That sounds like a
good place for a break.
So let's make a break.
Unless anyone's got some
questions, of course.
Yeah, of course.
[INAUDIBLE] always
got questions.
AUDIENCE: In Michelson
interferometer,
the object would affect the
intensity according to whatever
phase delay it introduces.
But in the Mach-Zehnder
interferometer,
it will affect the
spacing of the fringes.
Is that correct?
It will change the spacing--
we added this constant
slope in the signal beam
in the Mach-Zehnder.
COLIN SHEPPARD: I
think this tilting--
the tilting the one beam
relative to another you
can doing either sort
of interferometer.
That's not a
fundamental difference
between the two types.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
So I was thinking, when you have
a tilted plane, tilted mirror,
then you would measure the
spacing between fringes
to find out the object's
optical path length.
But if you didn't
have that, then you
would just measure the
change in intensity
to get the wrapped phase
and then apply unwrapping.
Is that correct?
COLIN SHEPPARD: Well, it depends
what you're trying to do.
AUDIENCE: To find out the phase.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah.
Yeah.
You're thinking of it varying.
It's a spatially-varying
quantity
that you're trying
to measure, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
COLIN SHEPPARD: So I mean,
very often what you do,
of course, is you
actually-- very
often you want the fringes
because they give you something
to actually look at.
So normally, if you don't
do the tilting thing,
what you'd see if the two
paths were equal would be,
let's say, completely
featureless, bright,
wouldn't it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
COLIN SHEPPARD: And so let's
say you put some object in there
which has got some
phase change, you
would just see a small change
from that bright, which
might not be very visible.
AUDIENCE: I see.
Yeah.
COLIN SHEPPARD: But for example,
then, if you tilted the system,
then you would get some fringes.
And the sort of thing you
might see, of course--
let's say you put in a
disk of material like this
and you're trying to measure
the thickness of this disk
of material--
so what you would find is if
it was nicely uniformly thick,
you'd find that you've got
these regular sort of fringes
across here, whereas
if it wasn't, then
you might find that
you get fringes
that have got some shape that
looks something like this.
So by looking at the
geometry of those fringes,
you can quite easily measure
the changes and the deformations
in the shape of it.
And as you change the tilt,
it would change the separation
between these fringes.
And so if you make
the tilt very small,
then you'd just effectively be
looking at just a single fringe
or no fringes, really.
So then it would be
actually very difficult
to see the changes
in the thickness
unless you actually made
very sensitive measurements.
OK.
So everyone back again.
Yeah.
I thought of something
else that perhaps I
could mention following
on from this diagram.
So in the lectures, the
system, as you remember,
was arranged to do
this sort of thing.
So the idea here is
that the two paths now--
this path and this path--
are roughly equal in size.
In the old days,
when people were
trying to do this with
non-coherent sources,
then you had to
be really careful.
And for example, this is a beam
splitter, which is actually,
of course, a lump of glass
maybe with some coating on it
on one side.
But you can see this beam
has gone through this glass
but this beam hasn't
gone through that glass.
And so these are all
things that you also
have to take into account.
And so in order to correct for
the optical effects of, say,
for instance, that
slab of glass there,
you might actually end up
putting a slab of glass
in here--
some sort of compensating
piece of glass--
so that this would produce
the same dispersion
in the two arms.
So there was a lot of
effort put into trying
to design these
systems so that they
would work with the
broadband sources and so on.
Nowadays, I guess, most of the
time we're doing it with lasers
and we don't have to worry
about any of these things,
but if you look in any
of the standard books
on interferometry,
there are a number
of textbooks on
interferometry that
will give you all
the information
if you want to go more into it.
So now we're going to change
step slightly from interference
to diffraction.
And so what's the difference
between interference
and diffraction?
The answer is really not a
lot, except that normally
interference we're talking
about two beams interfering,
whereas in diffraction we're
normally talking about lots
of beams interfering.
So you can think of the two
as really being effectively
the same phenomenon, actually.
And so we're going to look
at Huygens' principle.
We're going to go on to
the Young's interferometer.
So this really does
show, doesn't it,
how interferometry is
related to diffraction
because this lecture is
really about diffraction.
And then we're going to go
to a more complicated case
of Fresnel diffraction.
So first of all
Huygens' principle.
So I think at the beginning
of the lecture course,
George said a bit about
the history of how
Huygens' came up with this
idea quite a long time ago,
wasn't it?
It was even before
Newton or around--
I think slightly before but
around the same time as Newton.
So when people
still hadn't really
decided whether light
was a wave or a particle.
And of course, we
still haven't decided.
So times don't change, really.
But anyway so probably
now, looking back,
we could say that Newton was
the first quantum opticist.
But anyway.
So this was this
was Huygens' idea.
He was saying that if you
think of a light beam--
a wave propagating in space,
then at some moment in time
this is a wavefront.
The wavefront is a
surface of constant phase.
And he came up with this model
for how light propagates where
he assumed that all the
points on this wavefront
can be thought of as
being a source of what
he called secondary wavelets.
So each of these points
radiates like a spherical wave.
And then if you sum those
all up and calculate
what the effect is at some
distance in front here,
then that would then predict
what that wavefront--
what the wave had done
at a slightly later time.
So that's the principle.
And so quite a
simple idea, really.
And you can come up with a very
simple mathematical description
of it.
Unfortunately, it doesn't
work marvelously well.
And people put a lot
of effort into trying
to improve the theory.
And they came up with
some rather arbitrary--
they seem rather arbitrary--
factors that they had
to include in order
to get it to work properly.
So I think nowadays we probably
look back over all this
and think it was just history.
And there are better ways of
really tackling the problem.
But anyway, at the very
simple level though,
it's still a nice simple
theory for how you do that.
So if you want to calculate
what the field is at this point
here, say, you look
at all these waves
that come from all these
points on the wavefront,
add them all together
as phases, of course,
and that will give you
the field at that point.
And there it's showing
how you do that.
And then you can do it
again and again and again
and show how the
wave propagates.
So example, a hole
in an opaque screen.
So I guess this is pretty
well the simplest example
you could possibly think of.
Well, no, I suppose the
opaque screen with no hole
in would be even simpler.
Then you wouldn't see anything.
But what we do is we just have
a very small hole in this.
And so this is going to
act like a source that's
going to radiate like
a spherical wave.
And what we'd see on this
screen that we place here,
you'd see that is
virtually what we've
been looking at before anyway.
We've done that before.
So there we are.
There's the spherical wave.
And then we can-- are we going
to get some more on that?
Did something
happen then, George?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Ah! e to the ir.
Right.
Sorry.
I couldn't see
anything happening.
So this is the plane
wave coming in.
And now something's come up--
the hole is a delta function.
Did that just come up?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yep.
COLIN SHEPPARD: And now
something else has come up.
This is the spherical wave now.
And this is the
same expression we
had for the spherical wave in
the previous lecture, then.
So you remember this
parabolic type approximation
we made for a spherical wave.
This is called the
Fresnel approximation,
named after the guy Fresnel
who I guess must have come up
with this in the first place.
And you remember it's true--
it's going to be approximately
true if the x and y are small
compared with the distance l.
So you need that in order
to apply the binomial.
Right.
So there it is.
I'll just mention again
this i that someone from MIT
asked about earlier.
So that i then at the bottom is
saying that this spherical wave
is actually 90 degrees
out of phase with the wave
that arrives at this point.
So that's quite interesting.
So you can think of it
being like a resonance
sort of effect, I think.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: I
guess this is something that
Huygens' principle cannot
really explain, right?
This is why you have to
do more than Huygens'.
But we take it for
granted in the class,
so we don't get into it.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah.
OK.
Yeah.
So I think George is really
saying that Huygens' didn't
actually have that i there.
So we're cleverer than he is.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
We don't know why.
COLIN SHEPPARD: So
there we are then.
And oh.
Now we've got two holes.
I knew something had happened.
And the spherical wave is now
hidden behind here partly.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
More will come.
COLIN SHEPPARD: More will come.
So now we've got two holes.
Each of these is
a spherical wave.
And of course, when
we get two of them,
there's going to be two
spherical waves, which
I think is going to-- oh, yes.
Another spherical wave.
Ah, and another equation.
There we are.
So these are the
equations of what
you see on the screen for each
of these two spherical waves.
And if you look at
them, you'll notice
that these are distance x0 and
minus x0 relative to the axis.
And you can see the only
difference in these expressions
is this sign, plus
or minus there.
So we now want to
add those together.
And so here we're looking
at some observation point.
You've got to add
those things together.
Yeah.
So of course, as
it explains here,
if this distance-- we
look at this distance
and this distance, if the
path difference between those
is an exact number
of wavelengths,
then they're going
to add up in phase.
If they're exact number
of half wavelengths,
then you're going to get
destructive interference.
And you're going to
get a black region.
So there they are.
There's the distances d1 and d2.
This is the
expressions for those.
And again, we can use
this Fresnel approximation
to expand the square root.
And then d2 minus d1 is
going to be this minus this.
And you see the
only difference--
there's a sine there, George.
And so yeah.
So there's going to be
4x0 x dashed over 2l.
So one of the twos
cancels and you get this.
So the optical path length,
optical path difference,
is this.
2x0 x dashed over l.
So x0 is this distance here.
x dashed is this distance here.
So both of those are
small quantities.
And l, of course,
is a big quantity.
So this is actually, then, in
terms of distance, of course.
You know two distances
up the top and a distance
at the bottom.
This has got the right
dimensions of length
for optical path.
Right.
So as we said, that should give
constructive and destructive
interference.
What you're going to see
is just fringes like this.
So there's going to be
positions where these two add up
in phase and positions where you
get destructive interference.
So if the optical path
difference is equal to lambda,
then if you put lambda
equal to this thing,
then you get that x dashed
is lambda l over 2x0.
So this then tells you--
if you made this n
lambda, of course,
you'd have an n in here.
But this distance here to--
this distance to there is given
by this lambda l over 2x0.
So you can see the smaller x0
is, the bigger x dashed is.
The smaller you make this,
the bigger you make this.
What happened?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Ah.
That's facing there.
So this the spacing
of the fringes, then.
It's this lambda l over 2x0.
OK.
And so this is going
through the maths of that.
So these are the two waves
we've added together.
The only difference
between them is this sign.
So we can take out the
other things as factors.
And so these are the two terms
with the sign difference.
So minus i something plus e to
the i something gives cosine.
And so that is our final answer.
What you see, the intensity
is the modulus square of this.
These are all phase terms so
we don't worry about them.
And I guess in this
expression here
we don't worry about any of
these other things either,
these constants.
The only thing that's
important is this term here.
And we seem to have kept the 4.
2 squared.
I guess-- yeah.
Why have we kept that?
Anyway.
4 cos squared something.
And then we say that
cos squared of something
is equal to 1 plus cos 2 theta.
And so therefore our
final result, then, this
is then our expression.
Very similar to what we
had before, of course,
for the interferometry.
A background with a cosine
fringes on top of it.
So here it is.
It's very similar to
what we had before.
The m here is 1.
And that of course is
just like with the case
of the interferometer
that we described before.
You remember we
got m equals 1 when
the strength of the object
beam and the reference beam
were equal.
So in this case they're
equal, aren't they,
because the two slits
in the screen are equal.
If you made those two slightly
different widths or something,
then that would not be true.
Then you might end up with
something which didn't
have this visibility of 1.
So that's the first example.
So that one really
was showing how
interferometry and diffraction
are really the same.
Now we're going to go on to
some more about diffraction
and introduce the idea
of a transparency.
So all we're doing here
is we're introducing
the concept of a
transparency that
can change the magnitude
and phase of a wave
by transmitting through it.
And so this shows
here our transparency.
And you can see here
it shows that the--
I don't know what this
color, whether it means--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: So this means
the absorption of the screen.
But it might, I guess,
also change the phrase.
It might have some
refractive index as well.
Yeah.
And it changes in
thickness as well.
So you have to
work out, just like
before, the optical
path as the light
goes through this structure.
And it might change
both the amplitude
and the phase of the light.
So we can think of
this thin transparency
as just having a multiplying
effect if it's thin enough.
So you can use your
Huygens' type principle
to say that when the light
has gone through there,
it produces some
wavefront on the far side.
So the assumptions-- the
thickness I've just said.
Also, the features
on the transparency--
what's that mean?
What's that mean?
The features on the transparency
are smaller than lambda.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Ah, right.
OK.
That's why I was confused.
So this transparency can
change the attenuation.
So the black bits are
going to absorb the light.
But it could also
change the phase.
So phase delay.
And both of these
are going to be--
both of these effects are going
to be dependent on the material
properties of this transparency,
of course, and also
its thickness.
And as it points out
here, in some cases,
you might be able to think
of these quantities--
the attenuation and
the phase delay--
as being binary quantities.
They might only have
two different values.
For example, you might
have black and white,
or they might be gray scale-type
continuously varying-type
quantities.
And then the phase also
you can think of that--
maybe it's continuously
varying phase change,
or it might have
just two values,
binary values, or it might even
have multiple values maybe,
say eight values.
You can code-- people often
use transparencies like this
to code binary numbers
up to some basis of eight
or something like that.
So if these assumptions
are true, then
according to Huygens' principle
the propagation through this,
all it's going to do
basically is change the--
this is going to change to this.
This is going to change to this.
And you're not going
to get this affecting
this very much if this
assumption of this thickness
being very thin is valid,
in which case all it does--
all this transparency does--
is multiplies the field
going in by the transmission
of the grating to give
the amplitude of the wave
as it comes out.
So g minus is the wave-- is the
amplitude on the way in. g plus
is the amplitude of the
wave on the way out.
And this transmittances,
we call this
the amplitude transmittance
of the grating.
And you see it's a
function of position.
And as we just described, it can
be broken up into an absorption
term and a phase term.
And as we just said, those
two might either be--
they could be binary or they
could be continuously variable.
Yes.
So this is saying how--
you can think of
it as being very
similar to the Young's
interferometer, the two slit
expert experiment.
But now you can see
here we're thinking
of it as being many beams.
So you're breaking
this up into not just
two beams but many beams.
And each of these is
going to propagate.
But I'm not quite sure what
this is trying to show.
Yeah.
OK.
So it's pretty well
what I said before.
So if this thing is thin
enough, then this point
here is only going to be
affected by this one and not
by the others.
So then you will get this
simple multiplicative
sort of relationship.
So you can think of diffraction
then as being like interference
with many, many beams.
Yeah.
So this is saying,
just like we said
before, we are describing
this interference
of these many, many beams now.
When we did the Young's
experiment, each of the slits
was described by
a delta function
at a particular position.
And now we're saying
that in general, we
can think of this as not being
just two slits but an integral
over many, many apertures--
very small apertures--
placed at these points x1 y1.
Sorry, placed at the
points xy, I guess.
And then we're integrating
over all those points in order
to get the total effect of
all those spherical waves.
This is now we're
saying that g--
so this is g minus after the--
it's just saying that g--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: This is
just the shifting theorem.
And now we're going to
state that in there, are we?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah.
Yeah.
OK.
So this is what goes in then.
So this is our single point
on the wavefront going in.
And this gives rise to
a wave that comes out,
a spherical wave that comes
out, which is of this form.
It's the same as this
multiplied by the transmission
of the source.
And then this then radiates
like a spherical wave.
And then you're going to get
some distribution of amplitude
on this observation plane,
which is going to be exactly
the same as we had before.
And we've got this--
again, we've got
this parabolic phase
function that comes from
the Fresnel approximation.
So it assumes that x dashed y
dashed are much smaller than z.
So that's for a single point.
And now we do-- now we
integrate over all of these.
And the final result
for the amplitude
we'll see on the screen is
given by this expression then.
So this is the
incident wave, this
is the transmission
of the screen,
and this is the
bit that describes
the propagation of
the spherical waves
according to the
Fresnel approximation.
So yeah.
So this result is known as the
Fresnel diffraction integral,
or simply the Fresnel integral.
And so I mentioned earlier that
this approximation, replacing
the square root by
the squared terms,
is called the Fresnel
approximation.
So all of these--
Fresnel gets the name
of all of these things.
Yeah.
This is just pointing out that
this expression we've just
written down, the form
of this is exactly
the form of a convolution.
And so that's a very
important result.
A convolution, of course, means
it's space invariant, doesn't
it?
It means that you
can write this--
it's what goes in convolved
with something which is
independent of the coordinates.
And so if you think of
this as a convolution,
the thing you have to
convolve with is this thing.
So you can think of
this as being like--
well, it's called
the point spread
function or the amplitude
point spread function.
So if you put in some amplitude
and convolve it with this,
then you'll get something out.
So this is explaining
what I just said.
So this is the sort
of behavior that you
think of when you're looking
at a mechanical or electrical
systems.
You can think of a system
of being like a black box,
or in this case, a blue box.
And something goes in
and something comes out.
And we don't have to worry
too much about what's in here.
But you can express what goes
in, of course, either in terms
of some sort of impulse
response function,
or as we'll come to
in later lectures,
as some sort of transfer
function-type behavior.
But at the moment, we're
doing in the spatial domain.
So if we convolve this with
this point spread function,
then we'll get this
output, like this.
Now we go on to do
some examples of this.
And this is probably the
most important example--
comes up all the time--
because lots of optical
components are circular.
So lenses and so on, very often
they've got this circular form.
And so this comes up
time and time again.
And so all we've got to
do now then is we put in--
we say that our amplitude
after the light's gone
through this circular aperture
is 1 inside the circle
and 0 outside the circle.
And so that Fresnel
diffraction integral
that we have to work out
for this circular aperture
is just 1 inside and 0 outside.
So it's just-- you
just have to do
the integral over the inside.
So this is just over
the values of x and y
that are inside the
bright part here.
Now, so unfortunately, that
integral is a bit hard to do.
So we're not going to do it
at the moment in general.
But we will do a very simple
example, a special case
of what happens along the axis.
So if we put x and y
both zero, now we get--
we put x dashed equals
0, y dashed equals 0.
The integral comes down to this.
And now that is an
integral we can do.
And it's an integral that
probably a lot of you
have come across before.
The way to solve that is to
go into polar coordinates.
And so if you change
into polar coordinates,
you've got a theta and a phi--
a theta and a rho part.
The theta part is just an
integral of a constant,
so that just becomes 2 pi.
And the integral of this
other thing you can now do.
Integral of rho e to
the i rho squared over
something you can do
because the rho outside
is the differential
of the bit inside.
So to actually do
that properly, you
can make a substitution then.
Make a substitution that
xi is equal to this thing
inside here.
And after you've made
that substitution,
you now just get integral
of e to the i xi.
So that's something
you can just do.
And you get an answer.
Yeah.
Notice that you get--
so this final result
here, this term
here is just the phase
term as a function of z.
So that's just what you would
get if it was just a wave
moving in free space.
And then these other
two terms, notice,
they're exactly the same form.
This is an e to the i
something, and this is a sine
of exactly the same thing.
So that's what we get.
As I say, if you
go back to this,
if you wanted to do
this integral here,
it's a bit more complicated.
And so we're not going
to do that at the moment.
But I guess eventually we
have to do something about it.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Right.
So if we look at this
amplitude along the axis,
then, you can see it's got this
sinusoidal sort of behavior.
If you looked at the
intensity, this would just go,
and you just get sine
squared of something.
Sine squared as a function
of a constant over z.
So as it points out
here, then, it's
going to have peaks
and nulls, maxima
and minima, corresponding to
these particular values of z.
So you'll get a
sinusoidal variation
in amplitude along the axis.
The other thing
to note is that--
where's it gone?
Yeah.
Notice that this z and
this z canceled out.
This z here appeared when
we made this substitution.
And so these z's finally cancel.
And so the final result
has got no z in it.
Sorry, no z in the
modulus part term.
So you've got this
series of fringes
which are of constant
amplitude however
far away from this
aperture you go,
which might seem
rather surprising.
You might think that as you
got closer to the aperture,
it would get
brighter, might you?
But it doesn't, it seems.
I'm just trying to think quickly
why that should be the case.
But I'm sure it is true.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Notice
also the pi over 2 phase shift
has disappeared.
It got eaten up by the sine.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah.
That's true.
Sorry.
I didn't mention that.
Yeah.
OK.
So when you put in the limits
of the integration, then
you've got this minus this.
And this we replaced by sine.
But of course we need to get
an extra i to get the sine.
Yeah.
So the pi over 2 phase
shift is also gone.
The other thing that perhaps
is worth mentioning also
is that when we got down
to this integral of course,
this is just the
Fourier transform of 1,
isn't it, within this region.
It's the Fourier transform
of a rect function.
And even if we looked at
more complicated example,
if you add this circular
symmetry, whatever
this amplitude transmittance
of this aperture had been,
all we'd have to do is to
do the Fourier transform
of that amplitude
transmittances of that aperture
as a function of
this coordinate xi.
So that's a sort of trick
you can use to calculate
these things easily sometimes.
I think we're here
for the movies now.
So MATLAB has calculated
these things for us.
And when I press the
button, it will go.
But I'm not going to press
it until you're ready, just
in case it's very quick.
So this is a big aperture.
So what you'll see
is how the wave
propagates from that aperture.
This is actually
quite a big aperture.
So you don't expect to see a
lot of diffraction in this case.
When we come to this one,
this is a small aperture.
And as we said before, the
smaller it is to start,
the more it's going to spread.
So you're going to see a
lot more effect on that one.
And so you have to
look quite closely
to see what happens
as it propagates.
So this is a radius
of 40 lambda.
Now you can see some sort
of fringes appearing,
and it becomes like a bright
halo around the edges.
And if you look
very closely, you'll
see quite a lot of
fine structure on this.
And then the small one,
this is 10 wavelengths.
So this one changes
a lot quicker.
You see it's doing
quite drastic things.
By the time it gets to
the end, you've even
got a black spot in the center.
The fact that, of course--
we said before that the
smaller the aperture,
the more it spreads, but
also the quicker it spreads.
So you can see that
actually this one
has got a lot further
in the development
of the pattern than this one.
This one still looks roughly
similar to what it started as.
This one is looking
very, very different.
It calls this the blinking spot.
I've never heard of it
called the blinking spot.
But anyway.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Well.
Yeah.
I'm not even sure--
I always think of
the Poisson spot
as being what you get
from an opaque object,
rather than for--
but maybe that's the Arago spot.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
But Binet says
the two are the same, right?
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah.
Yeah.
OK.
So now the rectangular aperture.
The rectangular aperture--
actually it turns out you
can't get a simple
expression for what
happens along the axis
of the rectangular case,
unlike the circular case.
So that's probably why
George hasn't done it.
And so you can get expressions
in terms of Fresnel integrals
for everywhere, in
fact, for this case.
So the square case, then.
Let's see what that does.
The big square.
Again, you can see-- you can
see some sort of fringes.
And by the time it's
got to the end here,
you can see bright lines around
the edges, and also bright
spots in the four corners.
And then if we look
at the small square,
again, it's changing
more quickly.
And you'll notice that
we've developed by then--
we've got quite strong sort
of streaking along these two
axes here.
And in fact, you see
this final pattern there
that is the diffraction
pattern of the square aperture.
What does it say?
Well, we haven't done Fraunhofer
diffraction yet, have we?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: This is
introduction to it. yeah.
This is an example of
Fraunhofer diffraction then.
If you're a long way
away, you get what's
called Fraunhofer diffraction.
This is what it looks like.
And as we're going
to show later,
this is very simply
related to the Fourier
transform of the
structure, the object
that we're going to look at.
OK.
Yeah.
So this case here, eventually
this one would look like this.
But we haven't gone
anywhere near far enough
for it to look like that.
But eventually it
would get like that.
The distance have to go depends
on how big the aperture is.
End of show.